bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
session d'information voilà ce que l'on
peut retenir dans ce premier journal de
la semaine du lundi 20 avril avec plus
de 53% des suffrages la liste menée par
la maire sortante de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
remporte l'élection municipale partielle
elle disposera de 26 conseillers
municipaux il ya trois élus pour la
gauche et 4 pour les deux autres listes
de droite vous étiez l'invité de notre
édition deuxième débat d'orientation
budgétaire proposée à l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise en moins d'une semaine
avant le vote du budget le 27 avril et
par deux fois l'opposition n'y a pas
pris part soulignant le manque
d'informations financières mises à leur
disposition
la majorité elle parle de manoeuvre
politicienne le photoreporter reza était
l'invité de l'union régionale 16 un
collectif de photographes il est venu
animer une conférence à l'ugc skywest à
montigny le bretonneux et politiques
d'ong pour ouvrir cette édition sans
surprise analystes d'alexandra rosetti
la maire sortante de
voisins-le-bretonneux est arrivé
largement en tête du second tour de
l'élection municipale partielle avec 53
12 % des suffrages le conseil municipal
l'installation est prévue ce samedi à 11
heures retour sur cette soirée sur des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude et
enfin la liste alexandra rose et d'y
vivre voisin conduite par exemple
rosetti
2432 voire 50 prend 1 12% à 26 sièges
même si c'est un champion de trois
conseillers municipaux alexandre qui a
plus que réussi son pari elle augmente
son score du premier tour de cinq points
et surtout sa liste gagne deux
conseillers municipaux supplémentaires
par rapport au scrutin de mars 2014 la
liste offre également quatre conseillers
communautaires majoritaire à
l'agglomération
un carton plein après l'annulation de
l'élection en février dernier je suis
ravie évidemment surtout en augmentant
encore le score c'est vraiment un
bonheur quoi voilà puis gagner des
sièges et puis les quatre sièges à
l'agglomération
voilà donc je suis vraiment ravi jean h
listes de gauche progresse lui aussi au
second tour avec 18 57% des voix il
disposera de trois élus au conseil
municipal au lieu de deux dans le
précédent mandat je suis heureux d'avoir
d'être le deuxième c'est un peu notre
challenge pour le deuxième tour des
deuxièmes pour deux raisons la première
parce que on considère connaît la
meilleure opposition constructive c'est
une reconnaissance de nos années
d'opposition multiples ça prouve qu'on
n'est pas des opposants ridicule les
deux autres listes de droite qui n'avait
pas trouvé dont temps pour fusionner
entre les deux tours se tiennent dans un
mouchoir de poche quelques regrets pour
thierry gaston mon principal regret
c'est que la droite
l'ump se soit pas unis ce qui nous
aurait garanti avec les résultats de ce
soir un siège communautaire et donc le
refus d'union
de la liste d'olivier afonso nous prive
ses sièges là c'était à mon avis le plus
regrettable de la situation enfin
l'essentiel ce soir c'est qu'on tourne
définitivement une page
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir travailler
tous ensemble j'ai l'impression que
c'est le cas et puis le score d'avec
sera rejeté sans appel donc il ya une
continuité c'est légitime il est temps
de reprendre le chemin du travail les
dossiers sont nombreux qui attendent
alexandra rose heat et son équipe après
cette interruption de deux mois sur tous
les travaux sur la ville qui ont été
stoppés qu'il va falloir essayer de
redémarrer au plus vite et puis il faut
obtenir des conseils municipaux il faut
voter le compte administratif la baisse
de la taxe d enlèvement des ordures
ménagères enfin tout ce qu'on a laissé
en en plan le grand perdant de ces
élections alexis piette l'ancien maire
de voisins-le-bretonneux pendant trois
mandats après les élections de mars 2014
c'est lui qui avait déposé un recours
devant le tribunal administratif puis le
conseil d'état malgré tout il avait
renoncé à mener une liste soutenons
thierry gastaud aujourd'hui il disparaît
du paysage politique local il ne siégera
plus ni à la mairie ni à l'agglomération
pas de rancoeur pour autant je suis
moins satisfait de cette nouvelle
élection car elle s'est passée dans des
conditions normales et je pense que
c'est respectueux vis-à-vis des vies six
mois le conseil municipal d'installation
se tiendra samedi à 11 heures en mairie
oui alexandra rose était l'invité de
cette édition bonsoir mon sens au
lendemain de ce second tour de cette
municipale partielle comment vous vous
sentez forcément ravi oui c'est ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure peut-être aussi
très fatigué et puis très soulagé aussi
c'était une campagne qui n'étaient pas
faciles j'ai trouvé vraiment beaucoup
plus difficile même que l'année dernière
peut-être parce que
je pense que c'était une question
peut-être de dynamique l'année dernière
on était dans une dynamique
2-2 d'essayer de gagner là il fallait en
fait convaincre les gens il rassure et
leur montrer qu'on était bien aux
commandes qu'on ait conservé de quoi on
parlait et ça en dépit de tout ce qui
circulait sur la ville c'est ça que je
m'en sers et une campagne un peu dur
comme un oui je les trouvais très dur
parce que
j'ai trouvé que j'entendais beaucoup de
choses qui m'ont vraiment
pétrifié je me suis dit que les gens
puissent penser que je veuille du mal à
voisins le bretonneux ça me va un petit
peu posé souci donc on a on a eu à coeur
de montrer que on savait de quoi on
parlait et que évidemment tous autant
que nous sommes à liszt est
représentative de tous les quartiers car
on aime tous voisins et on a tous envie
que garde le visage qu'on apprécie et
coursan vous sentez un peu renforcé les
succès cette nouvelle élection
municipale j'avais un peu plus d'élus
vous avez 26 maintenant vous faites 53
20 12% ce que vous vous sentez renforcée
ah oui les chiffres là sont sans appel
et comme vous dites on a on a en plus
gagné deux sièges supplémentaires donc
c'est vrai que c'est le garant je dirais
d'une vraie légitimité je pense que les
chinois ont fait le choix effectivement
de nous redonner leur confiance et de
façon peut-être plus faire de façon plus
éclatante toutefois la guerre des
droites parce que pas un retenu c'est le
symbole de la guerre des droites et elle
existe toujours vous aurez deux listes
d'opposition à droite comment vous allez
travailler
je pense que c'est pas ça va un peu
au-delà de ça je crois que nous agissons
vous avez vous avez tous les trois la
même couleur politique en tout cas et
même journée alors après on n'a pas
forcément les mêmes orientations
peut-être pas de façon aussi aussi
marqué je pense que les quatre listes en
présence leur souhait c'est
effectivement de d'avoir une ville qui
ressemble à quelque chose que tout le
monde désire enfin je veux dire c'est
pas tout le monde veut du bien à sa
ville après guerre des droites j'avoue
que j'ai pas bien je n'ai pas bien senti
ce j'ai pas senti ça voilà dans la
campagne en fait c'est pas quelque chose
qui m'a qui m'a semblé flagrant et puis
je pense que ce résultat montre que les
électeurs c'est contrairement à des
élections peut-être national voire
départementale d'ailleurs je pense que
dans une commune les électeurs qui
votent pour un projet ils votent pour
une équipe pour une tête de liste pour
une personne au delà de voter pour un
parti je pense que ça c'est important
quand on entend dans le reportage que
lexie biette dit que ces élections
étaient respectueux aux idées davis est
mort vous avez raison quoi l'âge de
guéret est enterré un bon moi je l'avais
pas spécialement déterré mais
ça n'a pas été cette façon de dire les
choses a l'air de dire que on repart sur
ses idées d'irrégularités qui me semble
vraiment c'est comme ça que vous l'avez
vous allez interpréter après est-ce que
la campagne a été respectueuse et 10 6
mois je ne crois pas du tout ce qu'on a
essayé de leur faire croire aussi bien
par écrit que parler des rumeurs je
crois pas que ça a été très respectueux
de l'intelligence des dc noir et je suis
contente parce que je veux pouvoir leur
démontrer que tout ce qu'ils ont
entendus étaient faux en tout cas si m
me siègerait plus au conseil municipal
de voisins-le-bretonneux le conseil
municipal d'installation alors là c'est
bon on rappelle bien que c'est la liste
qui a été élu vous êtes analyste vous
êtes élu mais c'est pas encore maire le
conseil municipal d'installation c'est
donc ce samedi à 11 heures comment ça se
déroule un conseil de mme ici pas
d'installation que tous les visionnant
peuvent peuvent assister d'ailleurs ça
se passe et comment parce qu'il avait
commis à une délégation spéciale qui
était mise en place de trois personnes
alors c'est le président de la
délégation spéciale qui va ouvrir le
conseil qui ensuite passera la parole à
la doyenne du conseil municipal qui est
un membre de ma liste qui ensuite même
me fera élire et puis ensuite ce sera
mon tour de faire élire mais mais cette
fois qu'ils seront les mêmes qui seront
strictement les marques de commerce 2004
quelque telles conséquences pour la vie
municipale à vie politique municipale ya
beaucoup de chantiers arrêtés deux mois
d'interruption comme ça de vie alors
deux mois d'interruption c'est pas
anodin alors c'est pas non plus
gravissime mais c'est pas anodin parce
que l'ours qui m'inquiète le plus dense
que je vais retrouver là c'est par
rapport aux travaux je pense en
particulier aux travaux qu'on fait dans
les écoles en est et voilà j'ai cette
question est ce que on est encore dans
les temps pour lancer des appels
d'offres pour les pouvoirs les démarrer
dans les temps est ce que les
entreprises seront toujours disponibles
on a aussi des maîtrises d'oeuvre à
attribuer pour dérider rénovation des
réhabilitations en rapport avec un
contrat départemental donc ces questions
là
bon après on aura un délai effectivement
on sera au delà du délai réglementaire
pour la taxe d'enlèvement des ménagères
mais ça c'est comme comme le budget de
la communauté d'agglomération pourrait
retarder vraiment des chantiers ça va
retarder un déjà sûr c'est celui du
gymnase effectivement où il ya une
partie qui devait être fait cet été qui
sera faite en juillet 2016 mais étant
donné que tous les élus ont déjà siégé
connaissent bien leur dossier je pense
que les choses vont démarrer vraiment
très vite et puis je crois que les
services sont en attente aussi de
recours de la zi de se reprendre la
semaine même si je sais qu'ils ont
travaillé pendant deux mois mais c'est
vrai que c'est plus compliqué que tient
pas d'élus au niveau de vos dossiers
prioritaires évidemment ça sera là la
remise oui alors la famille a reçu
lorsque la communauté d'agglomération a
continué à travailler évidemment mais
mes dossiers prioritaires c'est vraiment
ce qui va concerner le quotidien de la
ville voient l'argent j'ai parlé des
travaux je parle aussi des subventions
je pense que c'est ça qui doit vraiment
avancer et puis ensuite effectivement il
y aller alors si j'ai quand même un
dossier qui me préoccupe c'est celui du
plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal jeudi qui me
préoccupe parce que je voulais prendre
le temps moi 2-2 concertée de faire des
réunions avec les habitants là va
falloir aller très très vite donc c'est
vrai que j'aurai moins de gens et moins
de temps j'irai pour consulter la
population mais je le ferai quand même
alors autre satisfaction aussi que vous
devez avoir c'est que vous apportez
peut-être conseillers communautaires de
votre liste à l'agglomération saint
quentinois est venue quand même la
crainte un moment là de l'entrée de gens
je retrouve posant de gauche à la casse
qui ce qui aurait en fait donné le
nombre d'élus de droite et de gauche est
une vraie satisfaction et servir à
appeler pour vous féliciter
ah oui les bandas casting oui bien sûr
et puis bah oui pour nous c'est une
vraie satisfaction d'abord effectivement
tout ce chiffon rouge qui a été agité en
amont ce résultat montre bien que nous
étions capables de prendre ses quatre
sièges et puis pour moi c'est sûr que
c'est toujours agréable d'être avec des
membres de mon équipe et pas forcément
c'est d'avoir quelqu'un de mon
opposition dans la majorité c'était pas
facile non plus c'est à dire qu'ils
étaient dans la majorité mais qui était
en même temps dans mon opposition
s'étaient pas simple et puis bah ça
assure
le quatrième homme je sais pas ce qu'on
dit ça comme ça
pas toujours évident et puis ça va
donner un peu de stabilité à
l'agglomération même si on sait que dans
quelques mois de toute façon on sera
rejoint par un certain nombre de
communes de droite donc voir sa commune
en tout voilà la casse qui avait
retrouvé le 27 avril prochain pour les
le budget on se doute que ça va pas être
facile le vote de ce budget et il a été
repoussé en raison des élections
comprends bien il ya eu 2 débat
d'orientations budgétaires auxquelles
l'opposition a pas souhaité prendre part
comment vous voyez ça peu de l'extérieur
puisque vous c'est ça oui je le vois
pleurer en extérieur mais ce que je
regrette c'est que je me dis que là on à
faire un peu à mon sens à une
manipulation politique parce que bon
n'ayant plus d'élus de voisins qui
siègent effectivement refaire un job
alors qu'on l'avait déjà fait alors que
nous sièges ou encore ne pas y aller
c'est un peu une façon de montrer de
faire des trains sa force ou sa
possibilité d'influencer les choses je
trouve je trouve que c'est pas trés pas
très responsable mais après les élus
font leur choix voilà en tout cas ça
donnera certainement des discussions le
27 avril à vos demandes le bilan est
aussi était question au sein du conseil
départemental qui a voté donc son budget
vendredi dernier vous êtes aussi une
nouvelle conseillère départementale et
le en binôme avec yves handball on
regarde ce sujet ce sujet par don signé
ou l'oeuf les vérifier et puis vous fait
réagir ensuite
un budget d'environ 1,4 milliard pour
2015 voté vendredi par le département
des yvelines et l'accent mis sur le
déploiement du très haut débit du cadre
de vie ou encore sur la réalisation des
grands projets d'infrastructures à
première vue la situation n'a rien
d'inquiétante mais dans le détail il
convient de souligner la difficulté à
boucler ce budget 129 millions d'euros
c'est la baisse sur trois ans de la
dotation de fonctionnement versée par
l'état alors entre hausse des impôts et
économie il a fallu faire un choix
toutes les marges de manoeuvre du
département on les a épuisés jusqu'au
dernier euro
donc ça veut dire que l'année prochaine
et donc ça commence dès maintenant il
nous faut mettre en oeuvre un plan
d'économies l'objectif est vraiment de
ne pas augmenter la fiscalité des
yvelinois mais le gouvernement
socialiste fait tout pour qu'on n'y
parviennent pas ce qu on nous rajoute
des charges on nous rajoute des
obligations et donc c'est un vrai casse
tête le département des yvelines n'est
pas endetté donc justement dans ces
périodes de disette c'est à ça que doit
servir la dette à condition qu'elle
porte sur les investissements et pas sur
les dépenses courantes dès que les
choses iront mieux naturellement nous
réduirons à nouveau cette dette est le
président du département d'expliquer aux
élus que dorénavant les subventions
accordées aux communes et aux
intercommunalités serait réduite ce qui
aura forcément des incidences sur leur
propre budget il va falloir qu'on fasse
des économies
mais de gestion faudra revoir certains
des compétences qui sont les nôtres et
surtout langue en pareil pour ne pas
pénaliser encore les contribuables
eh bien nous allons aussi essayer de
faire un budget sans augmenter les
contributions la culture compétence
facultative pour les départements fera
aussi les frais de cette vague
d'économies côté chiffres on retiendra
le 20 millions d'euros d'investissements
prévus pour les collèges les 15 millions
pour le réseau numérique ou encore les
530 millions d'euros consacrée à la
solidarité
évidemment une réaction de votre part
parce que j'ai dit vous êtes nouvelle
conseillère départementale moins de
subventions pour les communes ça vous
inquiète et des conseils aurait des
conséquences directes pour voisins
bretons ne vaut pour toutes les communes
je crois que tout le monde va devoir
faire un effort donc forcément c'est
inquiétant puisque l'effort qui est
demandé au département est demandé
également aux communes et demandé aux
communautés d'agglomération vraiment
c'est un effort collectif donc il va
falloir réfléchir effectivement de façon
plus intelligente possible et puis
chaque canton devra défendre aussi 16
son positionnement alors il ya comme sur
votre ville des concerts départementale
dont vous parlez de votre canton mais
vous avez aussi vers deux voisins
venteuse et aussi sur votre vie le
problème de la circulation de la rd 36
vous attendait forcément des choses de
la part du conseil départemental est ce
que ça veut dire que le dossier pourrait
être un peu retardée alors j'ai posé la
question dès vendredi matin parce
qu'effectivement je ne voyais pas
apparaître voisin retenue dans le budget
donc ce qui m'a été assurée c'est que
lorsqu'il y avait une ac ce qui est le
cas par exemple sur l'a 10 36 avec la
remise le département effectivement
apporterait son aide je dois encore
résoudre le problème de l'autre
carrefour tout sur lequel on a une
expérimentation ça ne concerne pas que
voisin ça confirme vraiment le canton
puisque c'est la vallée de chevreuse qui
qui arriva voisins donc c'est un dossier
sur lequel voilà j'ai déjà commencé à
poser des questions dès vendredi d'un
caisson est ce que vous obtenu des
réponses
j'ai obtenu la réponse que soit la bdeac
et puis je compte bien là j'ai rendez
vous cette semaine avec le président
toute façon
évidemment j'y suis allé pour ça j'y
suis allé pour porter des projets qui je
dirais concerne voisins et le canton
évidemment parce que tout est lié de
toute façon donc évidemment que je serai
attentive à très attentif merci pourquoi
les cendres a relevé d'être venu sur le
plateau du journal au lendemain de votre
de la victoire de votre liste aux
élections municipales partielles et puis
je rappelle que le conseil municipal
d'installation aura lieu ce samedi à 11
heures merci beaucoup à vous je vous en
parlais dans quelques il ya quelques
instants à nouveau débat d'orientation
budgétaire s'est tenue ce vendredi soir
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comme quelques
jours auparavant l'opposition n'a pas
pris part aux débats estimant ne pas
avoir assez d'éléments concrets en leur
possession la majorité elle parle de
manoeuvre politicienne la séance n'a pas
duré plus d'une heure
le 27 avril prochain vote du budget de
la casse qui les élus seront fixés sur
les choix financiers pour l'année un
vote qui intervient tardivement en
raison des élections annulées à voisins
le bretonneux pour respecter la légalité
un nouveau débat d'orientation
budgétaire a dû se tenir mardi la séance
avait été levée après cinq minutes faute
d'avoir atteint le quorum ce vendredi
soir pas de quorum à atteindre mais
c'est entre élus de la majorité que
s'est tenue la séance l'opposition ayant
refusé de siéger une nouvelle fois c'est
un regret puisque je pense que j'ai
organisé un deuxième débat dans son
budgétaire pour être en conformité avec
les textes et d'ailleurs ces mêmes
étaient même alors à leur demande lors
d'un des derniers concédé mer donc je
comprends pas pourquoi aujourd'hui ils
ne sont pas là moi je dis que c'est
uniquement police yeux puisque tous les
documents qu'ils demandent qui les ont
ils ont eu les audits qui ont été
présentés mais bon ils sont même partis
tout de suite après le début de l'audit
sur la culture sans attendre la
présentation du budget sans attendre
l'audit sur les finances ou ne se fait
balader depuis des mois on demande des
éléments qui sont les audits qui sont
annoncées par le président de
l'agglomération comme les documents qui
vont permettre de prendre les
orientations budgétaires quand on
demande à voir ces documents là on les a
pas donc on considère qu'on n'a pas les
éléments de base pour faire notre
travail des nues la seule chose qu'on a
eu c'est une ex fine synthèse d'un audit
culturel avec des tableaux où nous
demande de trancher entre un scénario où
est ce que voulait supprimer 1 million
500 mille quatre cent mille sérieux
exprimés en fonctionne pas l'opposition
a saisi ce vendredi la cada la
commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs pour demander à voir ces
fameux audit dont elle dit ignorer le
véritable contenu un contenu qui sera
donc dévoilée le 27 avril lors du vote
du budget on saura alors où se situeront
les économies à faire et quels seront
les secteurs directement impacté car les
élus de la casse qui doivent faire face
à une situation inédite une baisse de 5
millions d'euros des dotations de l'état
des axes ont été fixées maintenir le
niveau d'investissement dans les
communes recentrer les dépenses sur les
principales compétences et sur le
développement économique et assurer une
qualité de service aux habitants une
nouvelle commission finances est prévue
cette semaine avec les élus de la
majorité comme de l'opposition
samedi le célèbre photo journaliste reza
est venu animer une conférence débat le
à l'ugc de skywest autour du pouvoir de
l'image le travail de deux ans pour le
collectif union régionale 16 afin de
voir conviés cet artiste complet la
renommée internationale mathilde de
capvern elodie moines
invite à une conférence débat sur le
pouvoir de l'image toujours armé de son
objectif le photojournaliste reza part à
la rencontre tout d'abord la rencontre
du terrain des peuples d'une culture
puis vient celle du public et le
deuxième rencontre est aussi important
que
deux premières s'est trouvé des gens a
écrit je peux expliquer je peux
m'exprimer mais je peux expliquer aussi
toutes ces histoires que je viens de
voir sur terrain devient langage
universel c'est l'utilisation que je
fais de cette photo qui est justement
devenir un médian entre celui que je
photographie l'histoire que je vis et
les gens qui regardent c'est ça qui
m'importe il a fallu deux ans ce
collectif de photographes pour organiser
le rendez vous l'objectif apporter un
nouveau regard photographique à des
amateurs de l'image c'est un humaniste
c'est quelqu'un cible et qui sait vous
faire vibrer dans ces images c'est à
dire que quand que quand vous regardez
ces images qui bougent et hiboux
transmet l'émotion qu'il a fait est
qu'il a utilisée lorsqu'il a pris cette
photo graphic le célèbre photo reporter
attire les foules plus de 450 personnes
sont venues partager son expérience sa
technique mais surtout ces histoires
pour voir reza en personne parce que je
connaissais photos depuis depuis
longtemps je crois que c'est un
photographe qui fait de très belles
images il est très engagé c'est très
humain s'est très
c'est très touchant et voilà puis c'est
le monde c'est une image du monde des
photos qui sont assez riches qui sont
avec beaucoup de sens et puis une
esthétique remarquable à 63 ans reza a
reçu de nombreux prix pour son travail
son prochain projet immigrants dans le
monde un travail de cinq ans avec le
haut commissariat aux réfugiés
et ce mercredi dans l'émission
culturelle qu'est ce que vous pourrez
retrouver un long entretien plus intime
avec rza et puis rien à voir mais si
vous êtes fan du jeu des mille euros je
diffusée chaque jour de la semaine à
12h45 sur france inter rendez vous
demain mardi à l'espace à michel
petrucciani de villepreux à 18h30 pour
une session d'enregistrement allées du
sport pour faire venir ce journal
direction montigny le bretonneux le
stade charles jacques maréchal pour le
premier match à domicile à des cougars
contre et sin alors un résultat plutôt
mitigé les unis montrent un se sont
inclinés la première partie 11 à 8 les
joueurs de 50 ans nuit n'ont ensuite
remporté leur deuxième match 10 à 7 on
va regarder ce sujet signé de notre
spécialiste baseball qui est vraiment
devenu fan après avoir testé ce sport
l'amicale est et demi d'euros sur des
images de patrick avec de dixmude
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
ont lancé leur saison à domicile ce
dimanche pour leur premier match les i
montante accueilli et si nos stades de
jean maréchal et cougars ont perdu la
première partie sur le score de 11 à 8
ils se sont ensuite rattrapé dans le
deuxième acte en remportant le match 10
à 7 cette rencontre a permis de jauger
le potentiel de l'équipe dans ce
championnat de deuxième division ont un
bon potentiel oui mais je trouve qu'on a
une belle équipe fort
le secret c'est lanceur aussi le lanceur
sens en forme ça va et la frappe si nous
on répond au bâton présent me répète
mais le championnat c'est je trouve que
le championnat c'est la serbie et cette
année les équipes ils ont des étrangers
semblent 11 étrangers les amériques mais
c'est pas les miens on est en france
déjà on fera bien on défense bien sauf
que en hiver on s'entraîne pas beaucoup
en fait donc je cours un peu après cette
année les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux nourrissent de grandes
ambitions dans ce championnat la montée
en première division est envisageable au
niveau de notre équipe une qui est en
division 2 ces deux au moins atteindre
ce qu'on appelle les play-offs c'est à
dire au moins échoué en demi finale du
championnat de france et essayer de
gagner une place en finale alors
évidemment avoir un titre de champion de
france ça nous conviendrait tout à fait
pour atteindre ces objectifs les cougars
devons gagner les deux prochains matches
contre rennes la rencontre est
programmée sur le terrain des bretons le
dimanche 3 mai
voilà et si vous voulez en savoir
évidemment plus sur les résultats sport
de ce week-end rendez-vous dans quelques
instants dans le 7-8 sport présentée par
michael ennemis dont vous allez ce
journal est maintenant terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi la formation revient en
direct demain bien sûr à 18 heures il
sera notamment question de l'école de la
deuxième chance alors qu'un rapport
vient d'être remis au plan national je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée